this was kind of a dark week for humor
and free speech and make no mistake
about it our very way of life is
threatened and under attack but uh you
know me I'm a cockeyed optimist yeah I
want to look on the bright side and
actually I feel like there was a bright
side this week I saw a reaction from non
Muslims and Muslims alike that I've
never seen before when [ __ ] like this
went down do you think we've reached the
tipping point where people have just had
enough of this [ __ ] well I hope so I was
going to say you know when you were
talking about hacking that today the
hacking group Anonymous announced that
what they were going to do was take down
every jihadist web site they could fight
ah so this is hacking but I I agree with
you I mean I think you know Sheikh
Nasser Allah of Hezbollah yes said that
these people had offended Islam much
more than the cartoonists six years ago
he said that if I had been killed the
Danish cartoonists wouldn't have done
what they did so he's maybe yeah
moderated his opinion what do you think
yeah the the Iranians I mean when you
get the Iranians standing up against
terrorism something's going on
something's going on right maybe they're
cracking yeah I think one of the things
that's going on is literally everyone
feels threatened when you've now had
incident after incident after incident
where terrorists walk into our daily
lives it's not a political struggle it's
not a wartime event it's a kosher deli
right it's a coffee shop in Australia
it's we journalists ah we tend to forget
how often it happens and we're American
so we don't want to single out people
but when you look at that list just
since 9/11 then we had the Madrid
bombings and Oh for London no.5 Mumbai
the Kenyan mall Benghazi which was one
of 20 cities that erupted when that
movie innocence of the muzzle
was on the Internet Isis Boko Haram who
killed an entire village this week
Pakistan this week I mean this year last
year killing all those kids at the
school Canada the Parliament Australia
that guy and that's just the terrorists
let's not forget also governments that's
the thing I think that gets lost it's
inside the establishment and it's
outside
Saudi Arabia today yeah a blogger gets a
thousand lashes for log to blogger for
saying something that a priest didn't
like right and let's not forget serious
law during 300,000 of their ounces right
but I mean like Turkey the president of
Turkey said women are not equal to men
our religion has defined position for
women motherhood I can't imagine a
Western government leader saying that
and you know what we've said all along
is and have been called bigots for it is
when there's this many bad apples
there's something wrong with the orchard
well let me look can I just yeah I think
there I like I said the only this week
that had been a kind of mutation kind of
deadly mutation in the riddle of Islam
and I want to just say something about
that because I think it's this is not a
random mutation this is not what that
well-known writer of fiction Charles
Darwin said it was as the way in which
things moved on right now but this has
been a mutation that a lot of work has
been put into a lot of as you say
governments the from the Sunni side the
Saudi government on the Shia side the
Iranian government have been putting
fortunes of money into making sure that
extremist mullahs are preaching in
mosques around the world and in building
and developing schools in which people
whole generation is being educated in
extremism and trying to prevent other
forms of Education when those children
were killed in Pakistan what they were
what they was trying to stop was real
education
the term Boko Haram
Cole means book Haram means unclean so
they're trying to say that actual
education that is unclean they're trying
to create and does it this is the point
is that the we although there have been
this I mean you know I want to express
my grief for our fallen comrades you
know I mean I think this is these are
people who died doing what we do you
know right being rude about people I
mean you did better than me but in a way
we are the sideshow the this is a
project to seize power in the Islamic
world and whether it's the Taliban or
Isis or Boko Haram or al-shabaab or any
of these groups what they're trying to
do is to create a mindset which allows
them to conquer the world of Islam and
where the sideshow I mean I don't know
we don't like being the sideshow I think
that's critical for Americans to realize
it's not about us no ok and I know we
tend to always make it about us it seems
to me the real fight is not Islam versus
the West it's within Islam it's within
between yes the terrorists and the
tolerant it's between Al Qaeda and
here's the thing about that it is
Americans who are being beheaded by Isis
right now and here's the thing about
that I'm not making that distinction and
there should be a distinction because
obviously the vast majority of Muslims
would never do anything like this but
they share bad ideas this is the thing
that caused the big ruckus when Ben
Affleck was here was that Sam Harris
said Islam is the mother lode of bad
ideas and everyone went [ __ ] nuts on
this side of the panel but it is a guy
who shot up the these two guys who shot
up the cartoonist and the other day they
were avenging the Prophet they said when
they did a bad idea well you know martyr
Jim a bad idea
women ization it is too bad bad idea and
unfortunately
the terrorists and the mainstream share
a lot of these bad ideas but not not
entirely because I'm not entirely don't
I mean
don't come to me for a defense of Islam
you know it's not so that's like as I
once said to my mother that's not my
team um what did I say she said why do
you blame God for what these people do
like a wonderful piece of infantilizing
of the theater if God is not responsible
for people people do in his name right
of you know he's I've got a baby God um
anyway but it's very important to note
that what happened in France this week
was it an enormous I mean people are
always saying Muslims have to stand up
against terrorism well this week they
did you know at all at all over France
there were French people train
Jerusalem's standing up and say we are
French this is not our team not in our
name you know kay but let me ask the
other question about Europe because
earlier in the week before this even
happened there was a rally in Germany
and rally in Germany right away kind of
red flag but it was against the
islamization of Europe and that I know
people here right away though that
sounds racist but you know there was a
piece 60 minutes did did you see that in
November about London London where
you've lived most of us have travelled
okay there is a preacher there who
basically says he'd like to take over
the town he says ultimately I want to
see every single woman in this country
covered from head to toe I want to see
the hand of the thief cut I want to see
adulterer stoned to death yeah I want to
see Sharia law in Europe but this is
what Margaret Thatcher that great I'm
great admirer of hers called the oxygen
of publicity this guy unjam tawdry he's
a joke you know he's known in England
okay if I if you don't mind but when
people say things like that that are
offensive evil dangerous we must have
the courage to call it by its every time
that is evil that is
he made you a joke away and pretend it's
not how he showed up they showed a woman
in London walking out of her house in a
miniskirt and she was like in a
predominately Muslim neighborhood yeah
and all the men were screaming at her
cover up this is a Muslim neighborhood
you shouldn't do that and she says this
is Great Britain yes and then steve
Kroft [ __ ] her no but but I kind of
get man why people how do you think
people think about you the way I know I
like I kind of thank you very much oh
but it's the fight within Islam that's
most important it's not amenable to a
solution from the West that's not like
they're really deeply concerned about
what you and I think but what we can do
what we can do is not give a [ __ ]
inch right that's what we that's a
that's um um I am so with the Muslim cuz
you know I keep saying I'm the liberal
in this debate because all my life I've
been a liberal for the people who are
the downtrodden and the oppressed blacks
gays women bullied whoever it is and
Muslims are oppressed by their own
people that's a liberal thing but not if
they start going wobbly on this idea of
you know what
no violence unless we don't unless you
do the unless you insult that'll wrap it
ma you know I little experience with
this
one of the things that I wanted to say
is that I noticed that you know what is
it 48 hours since these murders right
and already the kind of butt brigade is
out in force you know free speech but
you know don't get that far
free speech but you know maybe you
shouldn't have done that free speech but
you know it's like you only they like
goats and as well I would just observe
that there have been many acts of
horrific violence women have been
subjugated in these countries for
generations and still I would just
observe that maybe part of the reason
the media is so outraged suddenly is
because it's about them where was the
outrage that's true where is the outrage
I've been trolling for it don't know go
date well I know it looks very I know we
might actually agree on yes it is today
but today in the news I saw that Isis
had issued a leaflet telling their
followers what the Quran said about how
they should treat their sex slaves yeah
well so that's going on nice it's in
writing you know uh but yes is on evil I
want to mention dangerous what you said
after the Boston bombing you said this
new idea that writers scholars and
artists who stand against orthodoxy or
bigotry are to blame for upsetting
people is dangerous and spreading fast
and here's what it is about me coming on
your show there's always a couple of
brothers killing people yeah that's
right yup was the last time but here's
the Financial Times they said they're
not condoning the murders they said it's
merely to say that some common sense
would be useful at publications which
purport to strike a blow for freedom
yeah when they provoked Muslims but are
actually just being stupid you know what
to a coward
courage always looks like stupidity no
this is [ __ ] is the swine an adult's
on there being a good
you know what it is wrong to kill
cartoonists it's it's going to be asked
to respect that no no I mean that this
is the you know there's that piece on
the FT that was very I mean you know
Brent Glenn Greenwald so surprising the
New York Times
unlike the Washington Post if you're not
having the courage to publish this is
the Washington Post was brave different
times cave she's basically sit down
you're rocking the boat you know that's
that's the theme song yeah of the of the
of the but Brigade and what they don't
seem to understand is that satire
political cartoons even novels what are
their functions is to rock the damn boat
that's what they're for what would a
respectful political cartoon look like
it says it doesn't it say it all how
insecure religion is it's such a house
of cards that if anybody says anything
or draws even a cartoon they get worried
so here's where you and I start to
disagree no because you just went from a
specific a dangerous evil set of people
calling on a dangerous evil ideology
which absolutely is a subversion of
Muslim but nevertheless no one's doing
this in the name of Christianity no
one's doing this in the name of Judaism
it is not real just of all Pete is not
religion first of all it is religion
it's just one religion Islam well first
of all if this was the 16th century but
it's not I mean I made that point my
20 parties agree I agree but to say that
it's not all religion all religions
haven't done it there are crazy
Christians there are crazy Jewish
settlers right now but that's crazy
there is and there is no moral
equivalence now in someone beheading I
knowing off the words of an innocent or
anyone who's worth anything
in his district you do exactly that but
they only I was the 69 I'm the one who's
making that point you're not God you are
the sky view of the same Sun yeah we're
out of the same side what this does it
has from the 16th century except but I
would but I'm sorry cam there's inside
Islam there's a group quite a powerful
series of groups trying to drag the
world back right who believe that some
kind of perfect society existed in the
7th century at the time of the Prophet
and that history itself is the problem
the forward movement of human race
through time that's the problem
yes if we could just abolish that and
get back you know what what is ironic
and I have said this publicly on many
occasions what is ironic is the truth is
at the time of the great Caliphate yeah
the center of the Muslim world was
highly tolerant and very cultured they
don't know what a caliphate is very
culture they have no idea what a
caliphate is